- [Voiceover] A high school
class is measuring the amount
of nitrate in a local stream.
To be considered safe to
drink, the maximum amount
of nitrate that can be present
in water is 10 milligrams,
10 milligrams per liter.
The class takes a sample
of 15 liters of water.
If the number of milligrams
per liter of nitrate
in the stream water is 3/4 of the maximum
that is safe to drink,
how many milligrams of nitrate
should the class expect
to find in their sample?
Alright, this is interesting.
So in this sample, in
this 15 liter sample,
they find that the number of
miiligrams per liter of nitrate
is 3/4 of the maximum.
Well what's the maximum?
Well they tell us up here. They tell us.
Let me underline this because
the maximum amount of nitrate
that can be present in water
is 10 milligrams per liter.
So what the class finds is
that they find that their sample has 3/4
of this maximum value.
So what's 3/4 of 10 milligrams per liter?
Let's just write that down.
So the maximum is 10 milligrams per liter.
In their sample they find 3/4
of this maximum concentration,
so let's just multiply that.
You can multiply that times 3/4,
which is going to be equal to what?
That is seven and 1/2
milligrams per liter.
So that is 7.5 milligrams
per liter.
The way I think about this,
3/4 of 100 is 75,
so 3/4 of 10 is going to be seven and 1/2.
You could have done it
other ways, you can say
10 times three is 30,
30 divided by four is seven and 1/2
and you keep your units.
So this is the concentration
that they find,
that they find in their sample,
7.5 milligrams per liter,
and they do this, they
find this concentration
in 15 liters of water.
So the total number of
milligrams they find,
well you take the liters
of water, 15 liters,
and then multiply that
times the concentration,
7.5 milligrams per liter.
Now the units should work out,
and they do indeed.
You have liter being divided by liter
so those cancel out,
and you're left with 15
times 7.5 milligrams.
So we just need to figure
out what 15 times 7.5 is,
so let's do that.
So if you have 7.5 times 15,
five times five is 25,
five times seven is 35 plus two is 37,
and then one times 75 is 75,
so let's see, five plus zero is five,
seven plus five is 12,
and then four plus seven is 11,
and you have one digit
behind the decimal point,
So, they would expect
to find 112.5 milligrams,
and there we go.